que on va vous faire un tableau grand
père on a déjà fait antoine de caunes
vous faire une interview tarzan d'argent
oui j'espère que tu mourras des dons
annonce jean loup d'inattention
jean-louis toi heureux moi heureux alors
évident de développer tard gens
développent pas tous mais quand vont
réfléchir
jean-louis toi amoureux oui il ya une
folie jean-louis amoureux longtemps et
ce à un moment où le chef du rhin
longtemps ça fait plus de vingt ans plus
de 20 ans comment vous faites c'est
génial je vois là bas quelques france en
gueule et puis après on sème encore
c'est bien tard jean louis thouard ich
mois moyennement riches moins que toi
jean louis doit payer trop d'impôts
normand à payer impôts j'aime bien
parler comme ça ses opposants peuvent
payer payer sans réfléchir
jean-louis toit de gauche au regard des
avants répondre toit de gauche moi
préféré gouvernement partageur un mois
pas aimer politique gonnard jour
toujours toi je n'ai pas aimé langue
fourcher mois avoir propre pignon mais
difficile à développer dans cette langue
est non oui toi père tu veux moi perd
pas trop cheveux ben oui c'est vrai -
regardez baignoire et baignoire rien
dire
au fond d'eux
l'émission de la grèce à faire moi aussi
jean-louis toi toi fidèles - fidèle au
cheetah pas dire ça si donc fermé gueule
toi fumée joins toi faire chirurgie
esthétique
moi pas faire chirurgie esthétique mais
après juin juillet ou à jean louis doit
faire concert bientôt moi faire concert
beaucoup concert moi et mes carottes
après disent qu'ils mangeaient 40 fois
que ne soit le connaître [ __ ] mois
avoir à croiser [ __ ] jean nuit toi
aimer bâti moi aimer beaucoup baffie nos
pas même tribu lui venir en ami a le
coeur bat si des fois visité mois whaou
2 e et puis merde qui rentrent à la
selon fo ne pas un plaisir oui moi
expliquer à ma fille autour du feu chez
moi pu rien dire mais pour du rappel
dans ce genre doit avoir gros sexe mois
à voir non pas grosse partie qui team et
ed avoir comparé avec beaucoup d'autres
sagas harry jean-louis toi moi moi
vouloir toi
oui